welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and the Mandalorian
season 3 finale is finally here there's
lots of Easter eggs hidden details and
things going on with this episode and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down the entire entry and
talking about where it leaves things off
I also want to give my review of the
season so far so stick around until the
end of the video where we talk about The
Good The Bad and also the grogu we'd
massively appreciate it we'd love you
guys if you hit that thumbs up button
for the final time and with that out of
the way let's get into the episode last
week saw the Mandalorian traveling to
mandalor in order to go into the great
Forge yeah they found moth Gideon's
forces and discovered that they'd been
mining beskar from the planet in order
to create the next stage of the Dark
Trooper now we also pointed out in our
breakdown last week that the Troopers
and jetpacks may be Imperial super
Commandos and I believe this is now
being confirmed by the creative team
either way he had Dennis scored out for
the briefing and we ended with him
unleashing his praetorian Gods on Paz
rocking Mandalorian inspired masks they
then kill Paz vizsler leading to a big
Cliffhanger that takes us into this week
now that starts off with balkatan and
Carl racing through the underground
while she reaches out to ax wolves the
signal breaks up and last week we talked
about how it was weird that no one could
get a signal out through the storms but
moth Gideon was holding 4K hologram
meetings with the shadow Council huge
shout outs to a lot of you though who
pointed out that the Imperial base is
actually likely jamming the comms which
might be the case though the signal does
drop out the higher ax gets anyway back
on the ground we see Beau firing away at
the Troopers and you might notice that
the blasts hit the armor but don't
affect the person beneath Ryan Airy
pointed on his breakdown last week that
the only time the Troopers go down is
for five dollars just like his mum
now the only time the Troopers go down
is when they're hitting the unprotected
areas like their neck and shoulders
they're also of course weak to
explosives which we see bow blasting in
order to get away really nice Star Wars
wipe here and we watch as man not as the
classic cliche prison escape sequence as
he's taken towards a debriefing room
using flame and breaking necks they
again have to think around the Army in
order to best their opponents Mando's
almost beaten though but Grogan comes in
and saves the day even using the healing
Mist that the igroid did during episode
8 in the first season Mano tells him
that if they don't fight back then
they'll never stop running and this is a
very important lesson for the young
padawand DeLorean to be learning at this
point the season so far has been filled
with Mando telling him lots of lessons
like this and yeah it's nice that they
carry on this aesthetic throughout this
episode too I mentioned this several
times in the other breakdowns but I do
see grago as being the future of the
mandalorians and he's kind of following
the footsteps of torvisler he was both a
Jedi and the Mandalorian and
thematically we have the idea in this
series that the best leaders of people
he can night people because of their
life experience I think in real life
that works the best too and to me the
best leaders are always people who've
seen the sides of people they're ruling
over because they have an understanding
of what things are actually like not to
wait too far into politics but we've
seen over the last couple of centuries
her leaders that were born into the
elite often don't have the life
experience of being poor to actually
understand how the decisions affect
those on the breadline that's why I
think Beau will be a good leader because
he's seen things from a lot of sides and
knows the needs of the mandalorians Now
grago can do this too and we know from
Yoder and yet all that his species have
long life spans and this also comes with
a lot of wisdom though all of the
characters in this series will be dead
in 200 years spoiler alert grogu will
still be alive and likely with the
mandalorians due to his ability to use
the force he'll also probably be an
extremely skilled Warrior and both his
lifespan and wisdom will make him the
perfect leader like to see how things
shake out far in the future and though
we're getting that movie with a race set
15 years after rise I'd be interested to
see things down the line away from the
Skywalkers anyway after the title
sequence we get the troops on both sides
mounting up titled the return this
finale is basically dishing out what's
almost all that action and we also learn
the truth about what's really going on
with the cloning tanks wasn't what we
thought but there are some ways they can
set up things that happen down the line
we see the mandalorians taking to the
skies and also watch the Thai
interceptors start dropping in hanging
like bats these were of course also used
in the attack on Belle's home and last
week the moth ended up requesting more
of these from the shadow Council the
known for their speed and alongside the
bombers they head out of the capital
ship Gideon looks over a map of the
location and nice little detail grogu
he's got he's got green marker right
shout out to whoever in the graphic
design Department did that Amando then
reaches out to the hero of the Rebellion
AKA R5 we see him using his own little
jet pack and this is something R2 busted
out at the start of Revenge of the Sith
man has to be stealthy as F because as
we know the there's Stormtroopers in
those corridors there's also even a
little mouse droid that passes by these
first appeared in A New Hope and will
watch Chewbacca scared off when Han and
Luke were pretending he was a prisoner
similar to that Death Star scene R5 also
hacks the terminal the same way that R2
did and we even see a little white block
popping out like it did in that film out
in space we see his Excellency of the
man knows to what's happening on the
surface and he remains behind on the
light Cruiser to use it as a decoy I
love the way the gauntlets cut through
the clouds missing interceptors by
seconds the cover allows them to get to
the planet and detect it elsewhere Mano
makes it to the barrier Shields and as
we pointed out last week these appeared
in The Phantom Menace on the boot
activating them one by one allows mano
to basically John Wick his way through
the forces bit by bit rather than
rushing them all at once again he has to
aim at the weak points and use his
brains to get around the armor and one
thing we didn't mention last week is
that mothgoodings possibly plundering
best goal because of what's happened in
the past he's looking to evolve the Dark
Trooper and we saw at the end of season
2 how Luke was able to cut through them
like a hot knife through butter because
they weren't capable of blocking
lightsabers best score is though which
is likely why he chose the material to
become part of his armor now as Mando
works his way through we see the mouse
droid setting Sirens off and I must
admit this new design Edition did make
me smirk off I've asked to bust out
another R2 trick to get a disc golfer
and it really adds some tension to this
hallway fight these are starting to
become a staple of Star Wars and we of
course had Luke doing it in season 2
which built off the back of his father
doing it in Rogue one when she Mando
makes it through and R5 is swarmed by
mice like like it's some weird old fairy
tale now at this point we see the
cloning tanks and learn the truth about
what's really going on Gideon is
actually trying to make more Gideons
rather than him being the one who clones
snug in all honesty I was kind of
disappointed with this reveal and it
does feel like they brought the card
running thing in originally to explain
what happened with pulps I do feel like
that's what Manda was originally setting
things up for as they even play notes
from snoke's theme in season 2 episode
4. so I believe that was the intention
originally but they've now moved things
across to make it so it's something they
can drag out looking back at the shadow
Council last week it now seems that
they've hijacked that plot to run it in
other shows we know that thrawn's
involved with the Ahsoka series and I'm
guessing we're gonna see more things
playing out there after our breakdown
last week with project necromancy I
actually saw a lot of good theories
about what happened with pups and
several of you guys said that the reason
Gideon might not have seen that
interested is because he was working on
his own one that was actually cloning
snoke unfortunately that's not the case
but the council discovering what Gideon
was actually up to could make them
realize that they can have other clones
in place like snoke that the Empire can
use as Leaders we discover later on that
he was actually attempting to wield the
force Sani was gonna implant this into
his clones this discovery could be
brought across in the project necromancy
and it may be utilized to probably their
own leader I think it will be all built
up from now with us likely seeing how
things connect from this to the sequel
Trilogy Star Wars has this weird thing
with disneywear because they never
really had a plan they're now trying to
retroactively fill in the blanks to make
things make sense for example the sequel
Trilogy wasn't originally meant to have
Palpatine in it at all and they only
added him as the villain in rise at the
last minute him somehow Palpatine
returned returning was explained due to
cloning so now they're kind of having to
go back and explain why this was always
the case when it never really was I
think that's one of Star Wars biggest
issues where they don't really have a
plan and just throw things out there
with the idea of like we can figure this
all out later anyway the shadow Council
are kind of like the new Rebels and just
like how luthina mon mothma had their
secret meetings these guys do too they
also appear in a circular formation
similar to the Knights of the Round
Table from the stories of King Arthur
this means that there's not really a
leader they all get to voice their
opinion equally and this is not that
person's that over everyone now Gideon
doing this to me is him basically making
his own Council that can rule the galaxy
say he had a version of himself in every
sector he could run the entire galaxy
and he wouldn't actually need a shadow
cancel at all because his face would be
the face of the Imperials using the
force would help him get the reputation
of someone like Vader and those people
would be too afraid to fight him because
he'd be everywhere at once this would
mean that he would have an advantage
that the mandalorians don't have which
is that they tend to just have one
leader well that that often isn't the
case and the main reason that they
constantly fall into Civil Wars is
because there are two people out there
constantly attempting to get power
however having him be every leader
negators from happening so you can kind
of see why he did it a huge allowed to
Ryanair if bonding out the difference
between the two sides we've seen how
with the shadow cancel that they're all
very much kind of out for themselves
moth Gideons of course working on his
clothing project someone thrown and
there's others are just one hops back
now the shadow Council itself was
actually formed engine project Cinder
which was basically a contingency plan
put in place in case the Emperor died
this involved the Imperials firing on
themselves and this was so that the
Republic couldn't Salvage their supplies
bilber's character makes talked about
this in season two and he brought up how
the Imperials turned on him and his
friends and wiped them out in their
thousands the shadow Council was very
much part of this too and it was
credited to bring the Imperial Warlords
together so that they could all be
killed at the Battle of jakku however
this plot failed unless they were able
to carry on in the shadows either way
though they're all very much out for
themselves whereas the mandalorians
represent putting their differences to
the side and coming together anyway the
survivors take the man knows to a hidden
part of the planet that's become an
underground Gordon the survivors have
thrived here by cultivating Farms which
sprung up after most of the mandalorians
left this is actually what the planet
used to look like before the Civil Wars
destroyed the surface and it shows that
life can return to this planet once more
the mythosaurs are very much symbolic of
the Natural Life of Mandalore returning
and this will Usher in a new era for the
planet now the armor actually prophesies
that this long thought extinct species
returning would hurled in the rise of a
Mandalorian leader and thus Beau seeing
it in episode 2 very much made that
prophecy true the mythosol was actually
originally the top of the food chain on
the planet when the tongs first arrived
Millennia ago amongst them was mandal or
the great who bested one in combat and
that's the Tong's name the entire planet
after him he made the first Mandalorian
helmet out of its bones and the
mandalorians then tamed the beasts and
started to ride them we actually had
some foreshadowing back to the return of
the mythosaur in the first season when
quill said this during one of the
episodes can't remember which one but it
happened your ancestors rode the great
Mythic sword surely you can ride this
young pole so they have a long history
connected to the mandalorians and having
one return very much ashes in a new era
for them in this reform Galaxy I'm
guessing that we will end up seeing them
being ridden at some point but let me
know below anyway the armor returns of
the planet and she brings the others
with her now we have been theorizing for
a while now that the omra is indeed true
cast and she was one of Darth Maul's
followers when he took over we don't get
that confirmed in this season
unfortunately and the Muff Gideon spy
Theory also goes out the window too as
she's not part of his group either the
main connection with her and Gideon was
the fact that they both had a horns in
their helmets which is something that
the followers of Darth Maul did these
were of course meant to Echo his
fearsome appearance and show loyalty to
the Sith Lord namal was basically the
kind of leader that the Mandalorian saw
was perfect for them due to him being a
pretty ruthless Warrior however it was a
bit of a bad bloke and thus those
against him spent a lot of time trying
to oust him alas though this this isn't
the case and I'm kind of glad I didn't
end up making the big Theory video I was
gonna because man's already taken enough
else this year in theory time anyway
back with Mano and Gideon we see them
facing off against each other Gideon
reveals what's going on and kind of
feels like a villain monologue to
explain why he's doing the cold thing
with the cloning I I thought was false
um but Mando puts up a pretty good fight
however it all goes to hell once the
praetorian gods show up in case you
missed our last video the praetorian God
name actually pulls from the Roman
Empire and these highly skilled soldiers
were tasked with protecting high-ranking
officials these were people like
senators and politicians and that's also
very much the same case here now these
are based off the emperor's royal guard
and you'll likely recognize them as
being from Return of the Jedi they were
the best of the best of the best sir and
were trained in all styles of combat
including Terrace Cassie this made them
Adept by theirs and like we saw in the
Last Jedi they were even capable of
going turtle with Jedi now they best man
know quite easily and then rush off to
gragu because I'm guessing he's still
the number one target due to him being a
force wielder elsewhere with Bowie watch
what's actually a pretty cool
live-action version of the Mano fights
that showed up in the Clone Wars though
I'm kind of met on this finale there
were bits like this that really stood
out and and felt like the creative team
were trying to show us things that we
hadn't seen before in live action
eventually it leads to Bow coming in to
rescue Mandel so that he can go and save
the kid and she ends up going toe-to-toe
with the moth this is of course building
off the back of last week with Beau
admitting that she surrendered to Gideon
originally here though she's standing up
to him which is character Arc now this
allows mano to go against the praetorian
gods and grogu busts out the force to
help his father ax brings the ax down on
the base aiming the crashing ship to put
a hatchet in Gideon's plans now he
promises to give boa warriors death and
this is a nod to how Vikings believe
that one hadidine glorious battle in
order to see Valhalla they of course had
a warrior culture much like how the
mandalorians do and I appreciate how
they at least give it on to that at this
point the dark side is broken and though
it could be seen as something tragic I
think it's actually good in the grand
scheme of things but it never really
want the darksaber in the first place
and it kind of became this mystical
McGuffin that everyone was fighting and
dying for holds far too much power and
those are being destroyed can allow the
superstitious Mandos to drop their
beliefs and actually come together in
the end the darksaber divided far more
people in it United and this also means
that the leadership can't be swapped out
so easily it could get to a point where
democracy actually comes into place
rather than who wins in a fight and thus
this violent Warrior mine's day won't be
the main thing needed in a leader this
just leads to more war and leaders of
Mandalore being violent because the only
way to be a leader is to achieve it
through combat that's what I think
anyway and we watch as the ship crashes
down killing moth Gideon I know he can
come back through cloning but I really
hope that he doesn't and that this is
actually his death because we've got
bigger fish to Frying out man fans being
beaten like three times in a row now so
I am hoping that they get others
involved this could even come in the
form of hux and pallion they've always
been restricted to the Legends and
expanded all so far but them being in
live action and having goals likely
shows what the creative team are
planning we have several sides and with
pallion being thrown second in command
down the line I think he's very much
gonna follow in the Legends outline and
become his right hand man pallian was
part of a group known as the Imperial
remnants and he was also someone who
signed a treaty with the new Republic
that helped end the war I think we could
potentially get lip service to things
like this whilst we see things falling
in a place where palliana prop up their
own is the leader I was genuinely
surprised that they went the way they
did with the sequel Trilogy with snoke
and I think that thrawn should have been
the overall villain I think they
initially wanted a Palpatine Invader
standing in snoking kylo so they shied
away from it but we can very much
explore what his rule would have been
like in the Ahsoka series as for hercs
we actually know what eventually happens
with him and I imagine that we'll see
his son Armitage as a child in one of
the other upcoming shows in case you
don't know uh hooks actually had an
affair with a member of the kitchen team
and from this game it's an Armitage
Armitage actually plotted and planned
away with Captain phasma and together
they used a toxin to poison him he went
to Medical droids but they were unable
to see what was actually wrong with him
and this was due to the poison being
extremely sophisticated thus he resigned
himself to a back to tank and ended up
dissolving into nothing whilst hux
pushed the story that he traveled into
unknown regions of the Galaxy Ahsoka is
probably too early in the timeline to
play that out but by the time we get to
Mandalorian season 4 we could see the
huxes and maybe even phasma getting
involved they might even reveal that she
had ties to the mandalorians or
something because of the whole helmet
thing I'll not Theory time that because
we've taken an L today but it just seems
like something to think about now they
may also be setting up the movie as well
and though I'm saying season four we do
know that Dave vellone is working on
that project it will be set in the
mandovers and potentially that will pick
up the threats here rather than giving
us a season 4 down the line takes about
two years to develop these things and
I'm guessing that if I can just be put
into a movie so you may be getting that
but if I say season four again yeah you
know I just mean the next chapter mate
don't kick off in the comments anyway
answer does settles we see that grago's
protected man on Bow by using a force
barrier his polls from the Legends and
it could be used both offensively and
defensively you can protect people like
what we see here or it can be used to
stop someone from escaping huge it out
to Simon a bearman on Twitter for
pointing out this might actually be
another Prof in Brenner's microcosmos
theory meaning that the inner circle is
basically the closest relationships that
you have this is very much an inner
circle slash micro Cosmos thing as we
have a father and mother archetype along
with a child anyway the barrier saves
our lives and we could to The Living
Waters to see paz's son once more in a
scene that Echoes the opening of the
season this is a baptism and the water
allows people to wash away their sins
and be born again Anew hello past visual
is gone it is possible that we'll see
his legacy continue anyone through his
son Mandalorian Legend is heavily tied
and with his lineage in the Jedi
Mandalorian top Isla is one of his
ancestors before his arrival the Jedi
mandalorians were sworn enemies which is
why a lot of their training centered
around being able to tackle them they
have the personal combat Shields built
to deflect lightsabers and also lots of
gadgets and gizmos to counter their
attacks tar walked both sides though
just like how grogu does and he United
them with the darksaber being used as a
symbol to bring them all together when
we were first introduced to Belle she
was also under the commander pre-bizler
who ended up being a wielder of the
darksaber he was killed by Darth Maul
who then took the blade and the
leadership of the mandalorians that were
loyal to it so there's definitely the
possibility that his child will be a
character that we follow down the line
and I do think they've taken a strong
focus on him for that specific reason
this scene kinda reminded me of the
ending of A New Hope and it's seen as
one big celebration for them beating the
Empire now we also see grago being
brought forward and Manda once more
bursts out the technicalities is to get
him added to the song it up scrago as a
son and this of course reflects the
ending of season 2 in which he gave him
away he's now gone from founding to
apprentice and his once more shows how
similar that the Jedi and the
Mandalorian are both took children at a
young age and trained them and their
similarities are actually what tar used
to bring them all together now under the
water we travel down to see the
mythosaur's eye once more and this shows
that the mandalorians have once more
built a home we close out with bow
lighting up the great Forge which
symbolically is the heart of Mandalore
about gadan being united as the leader
of the planet is something that's been a
long time coming making her first
appearance in the Clone Wars episode of
friend in need she's very much become
the quote unquote Chosen One Rebels
Xenon with her getting given the
darksaber and this scene's bringing
things full circle from that with her
actually earning the leadership rather
than being handed it the dark Sabers
something had sparked of the fire but
the forge being lit up builds upon that
to show the fire is now continuing to
burn I think the series has basically
been about about becoming the leader for
realest time and we end by showing that
she's actually worth it Hercules had his
12 Labors and Bo has been on a sort of
Journey similar to that we've had
mythosaurs involved the darksaber and
she also comes from a Royal bloodline
all these make her the perfect leader in
a situation like this but I do get the
feeling that peace won't last too long
we have the fact that she basically
enabled the Mandalorian Purge by
surrendering which caused millions of
deaths you can see how this will rub a
lot of people the wrong way and we may
see more Civil Wars coming down the line
Mandalore is a planet that's been racked
by them and we may see another one
slowly being sewn here with Bo as the
leader that's kind of why I'll lean more
with kroku as he doesn't really come
with a baggage and show last week with
ax and Paz that he can handle the
situation he's got the warrior side of
him from the mandalorians but also the
patience that comes with doing the Jedi
training he could also fit the title The
Mandalorian he's been there from the
start yeah he's there episode one and
thus I think with him as a focus
everything just makes so much more sense
but going off let me know if you agree
or not and with the darksabagon it could
be the case that the leadership isn't
contested as often as it used to be we
also have the fact that Bo's beating
Gideon as well now so potentially the
surrendering will be overlooked because
she's right at the wrongs of the past
much like how Mando bathed in the Living
Waters that's what the baptism before
could signify and maybe the characters
are all getting Fresh Starts Now
ahsoka's next up and I think we'll
likely see Belle popping up in that at
some point it's heavily tied in with
Rebels even recreating the ending of
that in live action to show us how much
they want to build off the back of it
now with Sabine Wren returning I think
we'll possibly see Bob brought across in
some way or another with Mandalore being
a big planet of the Empire is seeking
after it can be pulled into the war
against thrawn at some point down the
line bizoka is an ally of bow too and we
were actually introduced to her during
the asoka-centered episode this I think
we'll see her return in some form or
another similar to how Mano showed up in
book of Boba Fett they might even do
something similar to that where we get
Standalone episodes that get us up to
speed with things before we head into
Mando season four anyway we could demand
oh venturing out to a rebel ball look at
Kroger walk mate looks like a bloody
puppet anyway little cameos here in the
corner and he can catch series created
Dave baloney next to him is what I
believe is Peter Ramsey who directed The
Teva Centric episode earlier in the
season guessing that this was shot back
to back with that scene to make it
easier man the director just popped in
to say hello grogu spots an IG helmet
and I think it would be pretty cool if
this was ig88 but that might be me
reaching Mano does end up taking it
either way and this has dropped on ig11
who becomes the martial over Cora June
anyway Mando has brought a proposal with
him and he promises to protect the other
rim and even hunt down some of the
Imperial remnants this could potentially
lead into Huck's Empoleon stuff or it
may potentially even time withdrawn you
know from Star Wars celebration that he
will be played by Loz Mickelson which
I'm must admit is a pretty cool thing
Mickelson also played him in the
animated shows and we can potentially
look at the expanded lore to see what
they're gonna do with him I already
explained his backstory in the last
video so if you want to see that then
head over after this if you want to know
his future though we do kind of have a
rough outline of it obviously Disney
wreck on a lot of stuff so they might
not stick to this but thrawn was
eventually killed by his own bodyguard
Rook stabbed in the back during the
Battle of Billy bringby his final words
were but it was so artistically done
Brooke was killed playing his ship the
Chimera and thrawn himself was actually
resurrected in the expanded or 10 years
later I think they'll drop all of this
in all honesty and probably have them
taken out by one of the major characters
in The Run I can't see him being killed
in Ahsoka though and instead I think
he'll likely be a major antagonist in
all the shows going forward that kind of
ties them all together now we end with
Mano getting a place in Navarro just by
the flats and we see him chilling on the
porch as he races his son grogu I know
it doesn't take off his helmet or
anything so they're never beating those
Pedro Pascal wasn't on set rumors but
it's a nice way to end the episode and
also the season even if I did have my
problems with it I think unfortunately
this entire thing just suffers from that
Disney plus finale syndrome which if
you've been watching all the shows then
you know exactly what I mean they all
just kind of devolve into mindless
action and the plot threads that they
set up they though they give us answers
they don't really feel like they knocked
it out the park it's often the simplest
routes that it doesn't affect other
shows and yeah personally I always feel
like they chicken out the only time they
haven't done that is the season finale
of Loki and that didn't evolve into all
our action actually had some character
building a big choice at the end and
then it left things up in a cliffhanger
the other shows though however they
often do kind of drop the ball
um but yeah let me know your thoughts
below because I know I've been very
quite I mean massively negative on this
series but I have definitely felt like
this has fallen short now as for my
thoughts on the whole series you know
know I think this was an alright season
but it definitely didn't feel like it
lived up the hype that this potentially
had there was apparently a lot of
Backstage meddling which I'll go into in
just a bit and once you hear this I
think a lot of the issues with the
series will start to make more sense up
top though I want to start with a GERD
and I think they really told the world
together put Redemption Arc for both
Katan it took her from being the Obscure
Clone Wars character and to me she's now
one of the big names in the Star Wars
Canon I think the main plot with her was
worth coming back to week to week and
it's great seeing the Mandalorian
culture as a whole explored in more ways
than what we've typically got in the
past this is a lifestyle that's on its
last legs and the series focused on them
Rising back up and regaining their home
I think the production values of the
series were really strong too and when
you compare this to an MCU show it's
head and shoulders above it in terms of
Designing costumes those aerial battles
with the Pirates the ones in space
Mandalore chorus and so on it seems like
they're all ripped out of films instead
of just being TV shows I think that
works really well and when the series
hits its stride it all comes together
perfectly at color and back moment I
tell you see seeing my man I'm at best
he's back baby now on the opposite side
of this though I feel like a lot of the
elements of the series kind of
distracted from the main thrust and I
think once I talk about the rumors
around the season that'll all make a lot
of sense now Josh from denim nerds
talked about what he turned was
happening and it definitely feels like
it lines up with the issues that we've
seen with Star Wars in general Josh said
that lucasfilm had no idea how popular
grogu was gonna be at the end of season
one and once that time money started
coming in they realized he was a big
Cash Cow season two of course ending
with them going off with Luke and then
the studio had stepped in after they
realized they needed him back in the
show ASAP thus the r Commando was meant
to have in season 3 which would involve
getting him back was then shoved in the
book of Boba Fett so that he could be
back into the series come season three
it's apparently annoyed the team behind
the show as they lost one of the main
plot points they were planning on having
in season three and they also had to
deal with the fact that Gina's show had
been canceled too from what's being said
elements of the Rangers show were then
forced into this which is why we have a
lot of focus on the rebels and chorus
and in some episodes now whether that's
true or not I I don't know but it's
something that was reported a while back
and it seems to at least hold some Merit
when you watch this season I think that
my main problems do kind of lie with
that as well and I think we kind of lost
what made us fall in love with the show
which was the focus on Mando and grogu
that's how the series originally started
but it's kind of morphed into the show
about making balkatan the leader Mando
and Ragu have both taken a back seat in
their own show now and I think if you're
a big fan of the first two seasons then
there's a chance you might feel
disconnected I know the istan fold words
might get thrown around but I think
there are people who might just lose
interest because it's not what they
originally connected to those that don't
have a strong connection to the Clone
Wars might just not have the interesting
bar that we do and the viewing figures
being down could be because of this
direction change
grogu might as well not have been in a
lot of these episodes and I think that
the season would have actually been
stronger if they'd stuck with the
original plan to have more of his
training away from Mando whilst Mano
tried to make his own way in the Galaxy
now I know a lot of people's problems
are that Mando is now basically a
secondary character in his show and
though I have kind of brought that up
but as a Clone Wars fan I do find the
bow Parts really interesting if we have
to follow someone else then I am glad
it's her but it does make me wonder if
those rumors about Pedro Pascal all the
way back in season one and two were in
fact true with the Direction moving away
from him I am starting to wonder if they
realize they'd given him too much power
and then decided to shift things up so
it wasn't so relied on him it's just me
guessing but yeah if these things are
true then you can tell how they impacted
the story and then we have some really
great entries here it doesn't feel like
the cohesive Vision that the prior two
seasons were there's some very out of
place things here and yeah it just kind
of lowers the overall score goal that I
give this series there's definitely a
feeling of Studio interference here and
when you start having pop stars cameoing
things that definitely feels like a move
by one of the highers up and not those
actually running the show you've ever
seen extras they actually do a bit in
that with the the in-show sick command
he's running and the BBC basically force
them to have Chris Martin sharp in the
series unexplained so that he can sing a
song that shows about 20 years old now
but yeah things like that still
definitely happen I still think there's
good things in the show though but minor
things are piled above the Eight
Episodes stopped it from achieving the
greatness that it could have had I also
think they kind of dropped the ball a
bit with a whole bow and Mano thing and
instead of us getting actual conflict
between the pair we just had the
darksaber getting handed over which
lowered the stakes a lot kind of
compared to Westworld which I really
loved
um but lots of people fell off it and
now if you bring it up they're like that
series was crap if you think back yet
the first season was incredible and it
got so many people on board at the point
that by season two it had a really big
fan base though I enjoyed season three
and four of the show I can see why
others didn't because it moved so far
away from what it was originally that's
kind of what I think happened with the
Mandalorian as well and whether people
come back next time I think isn't so
much of a guarantee as it used to be
anyway that's kind of My overall
thoughts and let me know yours in the
comments below if you are in a
competition right now and giving away
the quantumania steel Buck to three
subscribers on the 15th of May all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe and notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode repeat the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers earn some mails to watch
then make sure you check out one of our
breakdowns on screen right now which
gonna be a fun one I promise you
hopefully I'll see you over there after
this and without the way thanks for
singing through the video I've been Paul
I'll see you next time take care peace